hi everybody my name is Eve Jeffers and
I'm a software developer at Ladd 126 for
Amazon and today and my lunch guys tag
along with me
so off to work and I'm on my way to the
Detroit office I've just arrived at work
and walked into the building and right
here we got a great view of the GM
building and Hart park and on the other
side of the park there's River and
Canada I just got to the office and I'm
at my desk the first thing I'm going to
do is go through my email I got about 40
miles to go my desk is kind of a mess
right now because I don't come in here
very often
get through emails so the next thing I'm
going to go through is code review
requests most of my emails I got this
morning were code review requests so I'm
going to open up our Garrett tool and
start looking at code and reviewing it
please add more comments and logging
code reviews took up most the morning
and now I'm out for lunch
I walked down Cadillac Square see all
the food trucks behind me I'm on grab by
D just got back from lunch and now it's
time to get some work done I'm opening
up by Ruggiero tool and I'm looking at
what's assigned to me for the bugs and
tasks that I have to do I'm gonna work
on whatever is at the top of the list
and unfortunately I can't tell you what
it's about but it is interesting and
cutting edge I'm still in the video
conference room and I'm about to dial in
to a stand-up meeting and the stand-up
meeting we're going to share what we've
been working on me and my team to keep
everybody informed and how to keep my
manager informed all right that meeting
was done and on to the next meeting the
next meeting we have is a planning
meeting for a future project which I
can't tell you basically anything about
but I will say I will be working with
Alexa alright that meetings done so now
I'm gonna go review some more of this
planning for this project and then I'm
going to go over it with architect make
sure I understand everything correctly
this is something I'm going to be
programming in the near future
and then I'm going to head home and I
think that's next time I'll talk to you
guys so I'll see you back there alright
folks so I'm back home and I'm working
my ona home office and as you can see
down here I got my laptop I'm working on
Xcode right now finishing up and
building here pretty soon I have my
devices iPhone
and Android device an Amazon tablet and
a fire TV hooked up and pretty soon here
I'm going to build and test the fix I've
been working on and we are building all
right so I've run two builds and I have
built two libraries and now built the
sample app so we can test
what's test the change that I did and
here we go and we ran tests playing
Elephants Dream on fire TV and it looks
like it is working don't have any
crashes
there's no crashes in the logs it looks
like we're doing good and now let's see
if my wife wants watch Elephants Dream
on the fire TV in the living room haha
okay so now that we're happy that
everything's working and I'll test pass
the unit test pass as well we're going
to create a commit and push our code
change to get alright so our code change
is up on the carrot ready for people to
review I sent out review requests and
help look that I've already got one
review let's see what it says needs more
comments and loglines
alright guys so that is basically a
typical day I'm about to call it a day
there's lots other stuff that we also do
and of course it's going to be different
from team to team that you work on here
at Amazon but I hope that gives you a
good idea of what it's like in life in a
day at Amazon